why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so before we get into our discussion
about original sin Issue Number Four we
need to do a rehash we need to go back
and uh make sure that we're refreshed on
where we stand following the events of
uh the previous original sin issue
original sin issue number three and with
the way things stand now what we know is
that Nick Fury is dead Nick Fury was
killed by Bucky Barnes after Nick Fury
had gained the Eye Of The Watcher from
the orb the individual who had first
appeared to us holding the eye of the
Watcher and who had um exposed a
multitude of secrets to the Marvel
superhero Community what we also have
going on here is an independent
investigation of sorts of course we have
Wolverine and the Incredible Hulk trying
to piece things together on their own
trying to figure out what in the world
is going on but more than that we have
three groups of superheroes who have
been set on the path of this
investigation as to what the Unseen is
and who it was that killed the Watcher
by some uh Anonymous individual some
person who we just simply haven't been
told uh what his identity is yet and
these groups are moonight gamor and the
Winter Soldier Bucky Barnes who were
investigating space and of course they
came across a planet that had been
killed by this unknown individual what
we also had is Black Panther Emma Frost
and Scott Lang Ant-Man and they were
investigating the center of the earth
and they found a multitude of different
bodies that had been placed there over
the course of years and years and they
had been building up for quite some time
but again we don't know who it was that
had killed these uh what we have for our
last group is Doctor Strange and The
Punisher and they're investigating
extradimensional things they're delving
into the Realms of Doctor Strange into
the various dimensions of doctor strange
and they're conducting their own
investigation as they come across
various bodies that have been destroyed
or bodies that have been killed by
whoever this Anonymous IND individual
happens to be what we had also seen is
that the common theme throughout all
these groups all these investigations is
that the bodies they had been that they
had discovered had been riddled with
Gamma or radiated bullets which tells us
two things that one gamma radiation is a
lot more potent than we thought it was
and that it is a force that can be used
to kill pretty much anything but that
also there's only one person that we
know of who is for the most part an
expert when it comes to gamma radiation
or is most commonly um associated with
gamma radiation and that person is Bruce
Banner from here we're going to start
with uh original sin issue number four
and what we see going on is that Frank
Castle and Doctor Strange are still
within the dimension the dimension of um
of man eating shadows and what we see is
that Frank Castle's reaction to Doctor
Strange talking about how there were
only a handful of people on this list
who could have done this is crazy talk
and that he wants doct strange to stop
but Doctor Strange simply replies by
saying that it's inherent it's a part of
who he is because because he's Doctor
Strange because he deals with strange
things that craziness is just an
inherent part of his personality but
that just because he's talking this way
doesn't mean that he's wrong but what we
see Frank Castle saying is that the
reason why Doctor Strange is wrong is
not because of the way he's talking but
because he doesn't nobody's talking
about from here we see doctor strange
challenge uh The Punisher and Doctor
Strange tells Frank Castle that if he is
the expert on mass murder and he is the
person who for the most part we would
assume to have actually been the cause
of all this
that he would have the best explanation
of to what's most likely taking place
and what we see the punish replying with
is that uh someone has been going into
the backyard of doctor strange and
killing uh monsters killing his enemies
and they've effectively been doing his
job for him and been doing his job
better than he has and so Frank hassle
theorizes here that this pisses off
doctor strange that it makes him angry
that maybe somebody is more effective
than he is at doing his job and it maybe
it strikes a kind of personal cord with
him but what we see here is that Steven
strange says that what makes him angry
is the fact that he's being lied to it's
not necessarily the fact these different
beings have been destroyed what we also
see going on is that uh Doctor Strange
begins to challenge the uh the very
basis the very concept of the Punisher
with with Frank Castle what we most
commonly see is that when he's on his
Endeavors and he's killing various
individuals or he's attempting an
investigation of some kind very few
people lie to him and the reason why is
because for the most part they know that
Frank Castle is a no noons man that he
is uh he'd be just inclined to kill the
person that he's interrogating as
continue to let them talk and so it's in
their best interest to tell him what he
wants to know in order to continue with
their life and so we see doctor strange
using this doctor strange asks Frank
Castle if it's been so long since
anybody lied to him or is it simply that
he's so used to lying to himself that
he's unable to detect when he's being
lied to
and what we see is Frank Castle
countering this and saying that the guy
they're standing on probably didn't
think that he could die of a gunshot
wound but he believed that right up
until the point where he did die which
of course is Frank Castle more or less
telling doctor strange that despite the
vast powers that he possesses he can
probably be killed just like anybody
else in addition we see that uh Doctor
Strange more or less walks away from
this uh argument and makes the statement
that their killer has been very busy for
a very long amount of time they've been
doing this for quite sometime and that
whoever this unknown individual is is
the person that set them on this path
and they knew exactly where this path
led to and that they this unknown
individual wanted Doctor Strange and
Frank Castle to discover this to
discover this evidence of what it is
that's been taking place from here we
see that Frank Hassel begins to uh more
or less I wouldn't go as far as to say
reconcile but to understand where Doctor
Strange is coming from and he simply
replies by asking him if he doesn't
trust anybody else and answers his own
question by saying good he says that he
that doctor strange isn't necessarily
dumb as he thought he as dumb as he
thought he was but what we see Frank
Castle doing here is demonstrating a
level of intelligence that is actually
kind of uncharacteristic for Frank
Castle not to say that he's a dumb
character but we see him saying that the
one person they need to be talking to
right now is the one person they trust
the least which is more less this
individual that set them on the path of
this investigation what we also say is
I'm sorry what we also see is that uh
Frank Castle and presumably maybe other
members of these investigation teams
don't know about the other
investigations we see that Frank Castle
uh asks that um I'm sorry replies by
simply saying that if Doctor Strange
said there's all of us if he said
there's more of us then who are the
others and doct strange says that if he
if Frank Castle thought that their team
up was a little strange then wait until
he meets the rest of the group and this
is an indication to us that maybe there
are only there's only one individual in
each group that knows uh for the most
part everything that's going on or at
the very least knows about the other
investigations that are taking place we
know that black panther is aware that
other investigations are taking place
because this unanimous or Anonymous
individual had spoken with black panther
about the team that he had formed but we
also know now that doctor strange knows
about the other teams but we're not
really sure if Bucky Barnes is aware of
the other teams or gamor or even
moonnight from here we switch back to
Bucky Barnes and what we see is that
Bucky Barnes has arrived on the blue
area of the moon now again Bucky Barnes
is currently in possession of the eye
since he had killed Nick Fury and taken
the eye from him but what we see is
Bucky Barnes talking into his wrist into
some kind of a communicator maybe and
telling whoever it is that is on the
other side of this Communicator
listening that he knows he's out here
and that he knows he can hear him and
that he's coming for him and so we see
that Bucky Barnes holds up the head of
Nick Fury and simply says that he's
bringing a friend from here we
transition Back to Black Panther uh Emma
Frost and Scott Lang and what we see is
that um again they're getting news
reports they're getting uh information
to them which tells them that uh tells
them two main things one that Dr Midas
is supposedly behind this event the Dr
Midas is in some way tied into what it
is that's going on and we see that uh
Scott Lang chimes in by saying that he's
heard of Dr Midas that he's extremely
rich rich but he's extremely weird he
says that he could see him being the one
that uh that killed the Watcher but not
the one that's killed all these
different aliens and organisms and
monsters and whatnot but then we see
Emma Frost using her experience with the
hellfire club to chim men and to say
that when men get bored when extremely
wealthy men get bored they'll do almost
anything to ease the boredom and so we
see her talking about how this idea of
perhaps going on a hunt for various
monsters and various individuals would
be a very challenging thing and would
probably eliminate the boredom in the
life of this very rich and uh and
powerful man she goes on to tell us that
when she was in the hellfire club
presumably when she was with Sebastian
Shaw and uh of course um uh Jason wiard
and various other individuals that she
had seen them use their uh powers to
manipulate other individuals for sheer
enjoyment for no other reason than the
fact that they're could they could what
we also see here is that Scott Lang
tells black panther that they're heading
to the surface that they're almost at
the surface and that they need to slow
down but we see the Black Panther
doesn't do it that black panther
continues on uh at the same speed um for
the most part indicating that they're
actually getting ready to leave the
planet entirely we see that Emma Frost
tries to use her ability to read the
mind of black panther but this is
unsuccessful now again as far as my
understanding goes with black panther
due to his mystical abilities and
various Technologies at his disposal
he's able to disrupt the ability for
individuals to read his mind but again
this is something that I'm I wouldn't go
as far as to say that I'm 100% sure of
but what we see black Panther doing is
replying to Emma Frost to Simply stay
out of there and Emma Frost describes
Black Panther's mind as a bear trap
wrapped in barbed wire that someone set
on fire which indicates to us that black
panther does indeed have some kind of
mental conditioning that keeps uh
telepaths from being able to read his
mind what we also see is um black
panther replying to a question of Scott
Lang Scott Lang asks black panther what
it is that he knows that they don't and
black panther says nothing he says
that's what worries him because for for
the most part black panther is one of
the most intelligent beings on the
planet Earth and so he's able to uh
decipher Clues and evidence and so on uh
far ahead of anybody else due to his
vast experience with technology and with
science and just his overall intellect
but the fact that he doesn't know
anything more than anybody else does
gives him pause for concern but what we
see is that their ship is actually
heading into space that their ship is uh
traveling towards the Moon from here we
transition back to wolver and the
Incredible Hulk and what we see is that
they've arrived at the venger Tower
where they've learned that Nick Fury is
dead and Nick Fury of course has been
beheaded but what we see is that when uh
wolver rain uses his ability to track
sense that he he realizes this is Bucky
Barnes now again this is one of the
elements of wolver rain that's very
important to his character that when he
picks up a scent of a of a person he
never forgets it and so from the first
time that he ever smelled Bucky Barnes
he's able to track him and he can
recognize his scent no matter where he
goes which is the reason why why
Wolverine is able to determine that this
is Bucky Barnes rather than some random
person and what we see Wolverine
realizing here is that he thought that
Bucky Barnes had been dead but
apparently he's alive but that he never
really liked him that much in the first
place but then the other question
becomes how was he able to kill Nick
Fury how was this able to happen but
before he's able to get too much further
into his questioning we see that doctor
strange and uh and Frank Castle up here
at this point we see wolverin beginning
to plead with Dr strange in Frank Castle
telling them that it's not what it looks
like that they weren't the ones that he
he and the Incredible Hulk weren't the
ones that killed Nick Fury and what we
see is Doctor Strange maybe perceiving
the fact that that seems to be the case
that it looks like Wolverine and the
Incredible Hulk kill Nick Fury and
because of all the lies that they've
experienced because of the fact that
they're wrapped up in this uh who done
it mystery of sorts and they don't
really trust anybody they're erroring on
the side of caution and assuming that
Wolverine and the Incredible Hulk were
the ones who killed Nick Fury from here
we see uh Doctor Strange use his powers
to bind uh wolver rain now again these
are the uh the Crimson wraps I think of
of storic of citak and again if you guys
remember our discussion about Doctor
Strange we had talked about the
octessence and various things and while
uh citak had lent his gym to the
Juggernaut for power we also know that
doctor strange derived some of his
abilities from uh from CIT himself and
so this is one of those powers where
he's able to wrap Wolverine in an
unescapable bind and Wolverine simply
just can't get away from here we see the
Incredible Hulk begins to go on the
offensive and uh in counter to this we
see that Frank Castle shoots at uh at
the Incredible Hulk with a multitude
with a barrage of bullets of course the
Incredible Hulk doesn't really care he
thinks it's sort of funny that Frank
Castle would reply in such a way and he
asked Frank Castle if that was supposed
to hurt and Frank Castle says no but
what we learn here is that the bullets
were miniature explosives that had
pierced the skin of the incredible ho
hul although not killed him however what
we see Frank Castle doing is detonating
these bullets and the detonation sends
the Incredible Hulk flying out of
Avengers Tower and out into the streets
below from here we see uh Frank Castle
sort of investigating the uh the death
of Nick Fury and maybe uh talking to
himself a bit when he says that there's
no such thing as retired they're simply
just dead we also see him discuss how
the Incredible Hulk may very well be an
idiot but that trick is only going to
work one time and so he tells Doctor
Strange they need to work fast they need
to find some way to either uh do their
conduct their investigation as fast as
possible or to simply just leave now
what we see is uh Doctor Strange again
saying that he's working on this that
he's trying to find some way to figure
out what's going on we see Frank Frank
hassle ask if the body is worth a closer
look and drct strange says no that it's
not indicating to us that maybe Doctor
Strange knows something that we don't
know which of course is something that
we'll learn later on in this story from
here we see that doctor strange uses the
eye of agamotto the third eye and he's
able to um to realize that the orb is
within the Avengers Tower and is
currently being held prisoner and what
we see is him saying that the orb is
somebody with which they need to uh to
speak with from here we see that doctor
strange and The Punisher are with the
orb and the orb asks if they're here to
kill him and Doctor Strange says no but
Frank Castle says maybe what we also see
going on here is the orb saying that
somebody stole his eye and we see that
uh again Doctor Strange replies by
saying that somebody stole a lot more
than simply just his eye but um what we
saw is or I'm sorry what we see here is
that uh the orb replies by simply saying
that uh that he did that some individual
did send them that this unknown
individual this mysterious man this
Anonymous benefactor is the one behind
all of this but we see the doctor
strange who apparently doesn't realize
what's going on saying that no one sent
them that they're simply just here for
the truth to which we see the orb
replying that the truth is they don't
know who they're working for they have
no real idea of what's going on that
they haven't seen this Anonymous man not
truly and we see that the orb replies to
this individual as the Unseen now again
this is very important here and the
reason why is because with this idea of
the Unseen this is how we're going to
see this story play out that this
individual is referred to as the Unseen
this individual the uh actions that he
had committed in the past are referred
to as his original sins and so this for
the most part seems to be the way this
story is based around but what we see is
the orb realizing or I guess telling us
that this unknown individual this
mysterious man is the one that had
killed all these different organisms
both in other dimensions as well as the
center of the earth and and uh in the
vastness of space that he's been doing
this for quite some time from here we
see the Incredible Hulk has returned to
the building albeit not to the immediate
vicinity of Doctor Strange the orb uh
wol bra and uh and Frank Castle and so
we see that uh that Frank Castle puts
his Bullet to the eye of the orb and
tells the orb to simply just start
talking or he's going to see what
happens when he goes blind what we see
is that uh the orb begins to say that
the problem here is that the eye seems
to be calling him it seems to be
communicating with him which maybe gives
us this sort of idea that the
relationship between the orb and the eye
can best be compared to Gollum and the
ring from Lord of the Rings but what we
see going on here is that maybe the orb
has formed some kind of relationship
with the eye the orb says that if he
listens hard enough if he tries hard
enough the eye can find him that he can
he can locate where the eye is at but he
says the problem here is that the eye is
going to want to show them the truth
once they find it and they're going to
want to look but that some things simply
just don't need to be seen from here we
transition Back to Black Panther Scott
Lang and Emma Frost and what we see is
that a new set of coordinates have been
determined and that black p Panther is
setting them on a new heading now what
this new heading is is something that we
don't know just this second but what we
learn is that while black panther won't
necessarily tell Emma Frost and Scott
Lang what it is that's going on
immediately that he begins to uh to
actually explain that he begins to take
a step away from keeping things shrouded
in mystery from his team and actually
offers an explanation and what he says
is that the call that he got was a call
on behalf of this Anonymous individual
if you guys remember our discussion in
the early videos of original sin we had
talked about after the death of The
Watcher that some unknown individual had
contacted um Black Panther and sent him
various uh forms of information various
documents which led to this
investigation and what we had seen is
that uh Black Panther had begun the
process of triangulating this signal
triangulating where it was it had come
from and so what we learned is that this
had come from a satellite this had come
from a satellite that had been totally
Uncharted that had been undetected
detected no one knows when it launched
where it launched or how it got up there
it's simply just there and so this is
very disconcerting to uh Black Panther
and to other superheroes because no one
really knows what's going on inside here
or what the purpose of this satellite is
from here we transitioned to Black
Panther and Scott Lang and Emma Frost
docking inside the satellite and or
docking on the satellite rather and what
we learn here is that again as they're
investigating as they're looking around
that
despite the fact The Watcher has been
gone that there's always somebody
watching here there's always somebody
looking and so it could just very well
be that they're walking into a trap that
they're the next individuals to be
killed on this list of uh of dead beings
but what we see is that somebody is
looking at them uh somebody is
monitoring them and presumably has a gun
pointed at them and what we learn here
is that this person is Frank Castle that
Frank Castle tells black panther Scott
Lang and Emma Frost to keep their hands
up to do not make any moves and we see
him talking to uh each individual in
turn telling them what not to do he
tells Scott Lane that if he shrinks it
he'll shoot him and he tells Emma Frost
that if she tries to read his mind that
he's going to shoot her in the head and
uh from here we see that doctor strange
appears and tells um uh tala tells black
panther that he would much rather that
Frank Castle's hand twitch than dror
Strange's hand twitch just because
Doctor Strange will be capable of far
more incredible Feats than black Panther
would I'm sorry than Frank Castlewood
but what we see is him also asking black
panther who side is he on which side has
he chosen here what we also see is Black
Panther and Doctor Strange conversing
directly where doctor strange and black
panther begin to uh sort of debate with
one another black panther says he's not
sure what side they're on that they're
trying to figure that out and what we
see is Doctor Strange saying that's the
same thing that's the same thing they're
trying to do trying to do that they're
trying to figure out who's the right
side they're trying to figure out what
in the world's going on here we see him
asking black panther what it is that he
found that led him here and black
panther says it's the same thing that
doctor strange found a series of lies
and a lot of bodies and we see that he
says he doesn't know who uh who began
all of this he doesn't know where all
this started but he does know where it
is that all the lies began from here we
transition to uh again Doctor Strange
telling uh these individuals telling
Scott Lang and Emma Frost and black
panther that they managed to get here by
virtue of the orb doing its best to
communicate or to track the location of
the eye what we also see is that um the
orb is no longer or as Doctor Strange
explains it is no longer in possession
of the Watcher's eyes that the Watcher's
eye is now missing but no one really
knows where it is what we also see the
orb saying here is that the eye is
screaming that the eye is near the eye
is relatively close to where they're at
but we see uh again black panther Doctor
Strange uh pretty much everybody except
for the orb arguing amongst themselves
saying that the orb has to have had
something to do with it because he
admits being on the moon and he was in
possession of the Watcher's eye and so
uh all evidence points to the fact that
the orb was the one who killed the
Watcher but what we see is uh the orb
more or less stopping everybody and
saying that the eye is here but that the
eye is not alone and what we see going
on is that Bucky Barnes is standing on a
catwalk of sorts and peering down on
everybody monitoring everybody and what
he says is that he doesn't trust anybody
but he says that in a in a minute or so
the feeling is going to be mutual what
we see Bucky Barnes doing is jumping
down and Bucky Barnes simply says begins
to communicate with them telling them
that he has Nick Fury's head and the or
I'm sorry that Emma Frost replies by
saying is he the one that killed Nick
Fury but what we see is again this sort
of argument going on between Frank
Castle and uh and Bucky Barnes where
Frank Castle says he never really liked
him that he never really cared for him
and that uh Bucky Barnes needs to get on
his knees before Frank Castle shoots him
and Bucky Barnes who of course of course
has prodigious skill that is beyond
anything Frank Castle has replies to
Frank Castle by saying that uh that he's
not a dope Pusher that he's not afraid
he's not afraid of a man that can't
protect his own children and again sort
of uh taunting Frank Castle here but
what we see going on is um um Bucky
Barnes says that the reason why he's
here is because he's he's in possession
of the head of Nick Fury and the head of
Nick Fury is the reason why he showed up
at this location although at this point
we don't exactly know how or why that's
happened but what we see is that before
he can continue that another ship docks
with the uh the satellite and gamor
almost immediately begins running in and
attacking Bucky Barnes from here we see
that Bucky Barnes and Gamora engage in
this uh extremely deadly cat and mouse
fight where Bucky Barnes is able to stay
on the defensive and avoid the uh The
Killing blows of gamor buck Amora viewed
Bucky Barnes as a traitor due to the
fact that Bucky Barnes had previously
sabotaged their ship and abandoned them
on the uh on the dead planet from here
we again see that moonight arrives and
moonight simply explains to everybody
that uh Winter Soldier had blown up
their ship that Bucky Barnes had left
them stranded in deep space and so
gamorra views him as a traitor and that
they had to catch a ride in order to get
back here with a friend of theirs and
what we learn is that the individual
that gave them a ride is actually Rocket
Raccoon now as far as I know this is the
only real appearance that we see Rocket
Raccoon in the original sin story from
this point going forward we hadn't
really seen him previously and it was
interesting to see his character arrive
in original sin because what we get is
this really cool uh confrontation with
uh with um Rocka wakon and The Punisher
but again we see the gamor and um and
Bucky barns are continuing to fight and
for the most part what we see going on
here with regards to these set of events
is this breakdown of teamwork we see all
these individuals all these superheroes
who have arrived on this satellite and
all of them are mistrusting each other
none of them Trust anyone and so they're
all suspicious of everybody else and
this is kind of the scenario you would
expect when so many people who possess
so many formidable abilities all exist
in the same place but nobody trusts
anyone in addition what we see is that
um Bucky Barnes holds up the head of
Nick Fury as gamor um goes to
effectively attack him and when she does
she strikes the head of Nick Fury and
the head of Nick Fury is revealed to be
a robot and this is when we learned that
this Nick Fury was actually a life model
de that this was not the Nick Fury that
we're familiar with and that this is the
most sophisticated life model decoy that
Bucky Barnes had ever seen Bucky Barnes
had used the chip within the head of the
life model decoy to bring himself here
to determine the origins of where it
came from and that its Origins came from
that satellite from here we see that um
again that Emma frosco was as far as to
say that all this started with Nick Fury
that uh that that's what black panther
had said indicating to us that maybe
black panther I'm sorry that Emma Frost
was able to read the mind of black
panther or that black panther had simply
just said it at a previous point in time
in addition we see black panther
rationalizing that none of them were
told the truth that they were that
they're they're not all here by
coincidence that this Anonymous
individual had effectively given them
all different pieces of information but
all the information that had been given
to them would inevitably lead them to
where they are right now which is the
location of the satellite from here we
see Emma Frost replying by saying this
doesn't make any sense that none of them
were working for Nick Fury or at least
they didn't think they were working for
Nick Fury but then we see that the doors
open and we see some person saying that
that they still are that they still are
working for Nick Fury at which point we
see Nick Fury and what we see here is
that Nick Fury is an old man that Nick
Fury is much much older than we had been
expected to believe in addition he's
currently U surrounded by several life
model decoys
of Nick Fury and so this is a very
puzzling circumstance to us we don't
really know what's going on here all we
know at this point is that Nick Fury is
an old man with that being said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end and in the next video we'll
pick up with what's happened we'll pick
up with the backstory of Nick Fury with
what had been going on with this whole
origin with that being said I will catch
you guys in the next video
[Music]
peace
feel